[موسيقى]
وهذا التهديد يتمثل في صواريخهم البالستيه
ومسيراتهم الجويه و صواريخ كروز لمهاجمه
الاهداف البريه
في توحيد دول المنطقه بينما يحاولون ايجاد
السبل الفعاله لصياغه استجابه المشتركه في
وجه هذا التهديد الحقيقي والمتنامي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وسعتقد ان تنامي القدرات البالستيه
الايرانيه الى جانب النوعين الاخرين من
الاسلحه التي نقشناها للتو وهي صواريخ
الكروز والمنظومه المسيره وفرت قدرات
عاليه لايران عبر السنوات الخمس الى السبع
الماضيه والان يمتلكون قدرات كبيره
وبامكانهم استخدامه هذا التاجيرانهم هذه
الليله وليس في مرحله المستقبل كما هو
الحال مع الملف النووي بل يمتلكون قدراتا
بامكانهم استخدامها فورا وهذا الامر مقلق
جدا واعرف انه جذب الانتباهى المباشر لدول
المنطقه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اعتقد ان الجميع
لكن كل دوله لها الحق في كل وقت للدفاع عن
نفسها وهذا يشمل اسرائيل
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]